but there's a grand master yan christoph
duda
and i was thinking he should have a
a child and name it zipity
and then his child's name would be
zippity-doodah
alexa just got really bright can you
tone it down
look how bright it is it's just it just
it's my i guess i could just turn it
around and then it's
it's less bright can still hear me too
okay so i was in the show opening tree
what i did because lily plays uh almost
exclusively on chess.com so i loaded in
her her games uh for
the black side and then also for the
white side
i was preparing england earlier i don't
know if i'll actually go for england but
uh but yeah
so so she has um i guess close to 6 000
games total
so for those who haven't seen this
before it basically creates a tree
of like all the games she's ever played
and then shows
the moves that she's played from this
position i wanted to check what she
plays
in yeah like mainline e4
because i know she plays sicilian but
then knight f3
ah did she play nightworf
oh she plays the classical oh
interesting
[Music]
i have a cool line against this she
plays e5 here okay
i might avoid that f3 could be
interesting
and then c4
i might throw in one of these because
usually
classical sicilian players don't usually
play against smarty bind
i could real quick check like maura
i'm sure i'm missing like some
recommendations there are a lot of uh
white suggestions closed sicilian is
another option
i have uh i just have like a few minutes
to to choose
yeah she would transpose into aloe pin
here
so i played knife three yeah this is a
line
[Music]
and then i think knight a3 is a move
if i'm not mistaken nice thing about
opening tree i can um
i can just open all the chess window
and then analyze from here
so she played
she's mostly encountered castling but
yeah 93 she's only encountered once
it's tricky because id is knight b5
so a6
and objectively it's completely fine for
black
wait castling we'll just follow the main
line so castling
she's played g6
g6 not the main move wow knight g5
i hope she's not watching here because
this is i'm already
discovering like some cool cool idea
um i mean e6 is most common
and then okay then takes and gets some
iqp
position
ah 95 is cool it takes takes takes is
the knight hanging
and it's my c4 idea
[Music]
i haven't looked at these lines like so
closely in the past
and more games on the chat so e6 most
expected
94 did she play against this
no she's never encountered knight g5
i think i'll go for the smith mora
because that's the one like tricky thing
i prepared right beforehand but thank
you dj l
gifting two subs to von papalot
and smack my bishop
okay it's smithmore time
um yeah so
i know she was in my chat when i was
preparing this but
i think she said she wasn't really
watching
um i have to remember the line so i
think it's g6 takes takes
knight a3 a6 castling uh g6 and then
knight g5
but at some point i take of e6 i take
also i should note there's a gambit here
if if black takes i take back and
just have some nice kind of development
with the bishops
okay so d5 is very similar just
transposes
it's very clear like she has a a pretty
classical repertoire
um if she was like more prepared for
these tricky lines she'd probably just
be punishing me
um yeah we'll see we'll see what she
goes for here
i think the one game i found in this
position she played g6
and i should know even though this
started as a smith mora
i guess people can see uh this
transposed into an alapin
like knight f6 um basically it's a c3
sicilian
yeah okay e6 is the main move
and then oh i prepared uh
i prepared the next two moves bishop
here and then 95.
yeah i was like right before the match
uh quickly check this line
so it goes to show like the power of
preparation
because i just save so much time
um
[Music]
what was the main oh the main move was
95 and the knight c4
so bishop f6 is now a new move for me
um very logical though
i mean f4 comes to mind but then knight
d5
i don't think black is threatening to
take
but i should probably defend at some
point
and if i play f4 and knight d5 there is
knight c4
like which oh then we trade
i'm not sure what to do
actually that line might be okay
i took a lot of time i should have
actually found like an easier move to
play
but it might get sharp soon
it's knight d5 knight c4 so what i'm
calculating is knight takes e3
knight takes g6 we trade queens and
minor pieces
black would have the bishop pair but i
have two knights
that's a good move
i play d5
and knight c2 is also a legal move
i want to be tricky though
i want to make it so she like takes the
pawn and then i'm
i have tricks but
oh wait this is
that's a consideration d5
idea being i'm hitting the
knight and if knight takes i play knight
c4
it's essentially a gambit i'm just queen
e7
yeah i'm not not thrilled with the
position actually
queen h5 doesn't really do much
okay let's play nice c2 i'm just going
to be solid
um it's sometimes the problem with like
preparing something i've never played
before
uh if if he deviates from my prep then
i'll be on my own
and just not understand the position
um queen h5 no
let's save the bishop
bishop might maneuver to c3
so i was up about a minute after the
opening and now
uh now i'm like down a minute almost
okay so i'll put the bishop on c3 gotta
play quick
logical moves i mean black is still a
little bit underdeveloped
uh queen d3
that's actually a very strong move
take six i'm gonna play queen d3 because
if black takes i
might have rook team one or maybe take
some nine rock d1
i really have to stay focused here
sweet trade there's oh there's that move
too
i'm losing upon
had to defend but now i'm losing this
pawn too
but there might be some rook to one idea
but maybe not
some cool like rook f7 sack
which probably doesn't work the problem
is takes there's 92 is a threat
so maybe takes i play
some sad king h1
okay i was more scared about takes but i
guess there's some risk
bishop b4 here
eh i mean d5
i didn't calculate this at all whoa it's
our raid
oh alert box is hidden thanks for
reading
hey it's grandmaster gary appreciate you
reading
oops okay i should focus on the game
i have three seconds left
welcome readers if you're just joining
i'm about to flag
but leila is also about to flag
uh let's what to do
this move along with the thing
ah that was a really bad move
okay i'm probably gonna lose this
unless i went on time
okay so i have this all comes down to
the pawn
[Music]
which is now blockaded
that crumbled really quickly
uh playlist move defend
i should probably resign out of respect
but there's a pin
let's um let's try and trade all the
pawns
yeah very well played
okay i resign ah
okay there goes my my uh i guess some of
my reading
but she played that well um
okay shout out to gary i do appreciate
the raid i probably shouldn't have been
trying to fix overlay in such a
situation
uh let me bring this game into the
analysis board i mean she
she did well to um i guess again come
out of the opening alive i took a lot of
time
after the opening
and it was another it's unfortunate
because it was nice like opening
preparation
i was prepared for this and then this
it's like the last bit of my prep
but bishop f6 f4
probably was premature
um yeah she played very very solidly
even though black's a little bit passive
here there are still squares to work
with
and my d-pawn got a bit
weak um
and here i'm probably already worse
and then here yeah 33. 93 was a panic
move
i really wanted to take sack my queen
and then
do things but it's only one check the
pawn would just
be blockaded lele did you want to
analyze
yes cool i'm in the same analysis board
um i'll invite you again now
oh wait oh you invited me okay yeah
look here we go so
you you probably weren't aware of this
but i i prepared this like right before
we hopped on call like i was showing
this to my stream
and i know you took some time
in this position uh to decide
i guess how to develop um i i found like
one game you played where you played g6
yes i know i remember this game which
g6 it's a logical move but um it runs
into knight g5
and this i was really excited to um to
like blitz this out
where i would provoke e6 and then knight
e4 and mike gets a lot of
initiative
but e6 it's like very kind of the
standard way of playing
[Music]
and it's a line i think you did a nice
job neutralizing
yes i remember this game when i played
g6 and ig5
i lost in online so it's i decided to
play much like
a relaxed e6 and just all of my pieces
and right yeah and i
i like the opening was new for me so i
didn't fully understand what the plans
were in the position
like a big issue is the queen side
pieces are a bit sidelined
like a6 was strong to prevent the knight
from coming here
and um this is still preparation for me
like knight e5
uh i'd seen before but bishop f6 was a
new move
and um
[Music]
i i did some quick analysis here i
should have i should have just
improved my rooks and leave them right
here
and not play f4 which turned out to be
weakening
uh yes like well the thing is that
the four pawn is still hanging and you
what was your plan after you played it
for
so i just wanted to reinforce the knight
um and like eventually
what was i calculating i was actually
calculating knight d5
looks attractive for you and then i was
going to
counter with knight c4 attacking your
queen
and this is really the main thing i
calculated when i play that 4 is takes
takes
takes takes and then it's kind of a cool
setup with the knights and your rooks
tie down to the pawn
you're like your your pieces are a
little bit hard to develop here
but you played really well and just kind
of using the squares that you had like
rook d8 pressuring the pawn
and then i think i was just in in
trouble like very quickly
uh i was expecting that this operation
would be tough for me because
as i have played many times in online i
had problems
in this position but uh
yes after six like i think f4 was not
necessary here
yeah um because i always have these
these uh
tricks against the b6 knight so if i
play rook c1
it's still probably not good for you
like of course you want to take
on e5 with material but it just doesn't
work in these lines because your queen
gets hit
and it's tied down to defending the
knights so
even if if this happens then it's
already winning for white because two
things are attacked and
if bishop to ya i would just take it yes
and and uh before before we switch to
like
game and analyzing i have channel points
you are like if someone redeem
these channel points i can put headwind
oh so i need to put admins yeah
i need to choose like i have so many
headlines
literally my my comment you lost
watching we're putting it back so
i'm gonna put this i'll just warm it i
think this fits well
it's red yeah i used to have a channel
point redemption
to uh to go blind i were to just wear a
blindfold but i have that turned off
uh at least for this stream